put okay we're good to go we are live
stream so I'll kick it off um welcome to
counselor staff and those viewing on
live stream to the ltp workshop budget
in financial policies we've got some
apologies pania it will be late Alex
will also be late and
Barry um stew any other apologies from
the
floor okay we'll note those um now we do
probably want to
move um the session to
um public excluded and we'll just sort
of go through some reasons why for that
um so
um yeah do you want me to read those
read that before drafted out for the
reasons why yeah so
um as as we know and it's been disclosed
this is a long-term Financial strategy
Workshop the reason for passing the
resolution to move to public
excluded um in relation to each matter
and specific grounds under Section 481
of the local government official
information and meetings act
1987 um for the passing of this
resolution as follows it's to do with
long-term plan and it's to enable any
local Authority holding the information
to carry out without prejudice or
disadvantage commercial activities and
under Section
7.2 point one enable any local Authority
holding the information to carry on
without prejudice or disadvantage
negotiations including commercial or
industrial negotiations in section
481a that the public conduct of this
item would in would be likely to result
in the disclosure of information for
which good reason for withholding would
exist under Section 7
um there are matters that are
commercially sensitive that we want to
discuss today with relation to sort of
long-term plan budget and financial
policies um that are commercially
sensitive and that will be
explored as the financial strategy is
explored and worked through and the
matters that also relate to staff levels
and specific areas that impact on
Industrial negotiations or could impact
on Industrial
negotiations so um yeah is that clear
for all those present okay so no do you
want to sort of add further to that yeah
just to say that we our uh Council track
record is probably in ahead of every
other Council in the country comes
openness but there are some areas that
you still need to yeah work your way
through quietly um certainly on
Commercial sensitivity and if we are
looking to uh for want of a better words
but for the people watching uh cut our
cloth in Opex yes annual operating cost
um that may impact on staff so we need
to be sensitive about that and not have
that in a public meeting yeah yeah okay
till we make decisions on it yeah true
okay do we we need a move in a second
that I'll move yeah okay um second yeah
Tom moving Noby second all those in
favor I okay against
carried